اخيرا حسم المرشح الخاسر في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه بجولتها الاولى سنان
اوغان قراره ودعم مرشح تحالف الشعب الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان
اطلبوا من ناخبين الذين صوتوا لنا في
الجوله الاولى التصويت للسيد اردوغان في
الجوله الثانيه
اوغان دعم مجددا الى ترحيل اللاجئين
معتبرا ان مشكلتهم تمثل قضيه امن قوميا
للبلاد ايضا انتقد حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
الكردي وقال ان تحالف الامه المعارض لم
يقنعه موقف اوغان اشعل الجدل في التحالف
الذي يمثله وهو تحالف الاجداد فمنذ اعلان
نتائج الانتخابات البرلمانيه والرئاسيه
ظهر للعلن ان التحالف ليس على قلب رجل
واحد فيما يخص الجوله الثانيه حزب العداله
وهو حزب صغير داخل التحالف قرر مرشح تحالف
الامه كمال كلجدار اوغلو بينما اعلن اوميت
اوزداغ الذي يعرف بمواقفه التي توصف
بالعنصريه وهو رئيس حزب النصر الذي ينتمي
اليه اوغان اعلن ان قرار المرشح الرئاسي
بدعم اردوغان لا يعبر عن وجهه نظر الحزب
انما وجهه نظره الشخصيه لا يمكن ان يكون
هناك تصويت كامل من قبل كتله سنان اوغان
للرئيس اردوغان هذا موقف شخصي لسنان اوغان
وبالتالي تحالف الاجداد لا يمكن ان يذهب
كله للرئيس اردوغان لان ذلك سوف يتعارض مع
قيامهم ومباديهم التي اعلن عنها والتي دخل
مرشحهم منافسا لهم في الانتخابات وحصل
اوغام في الجوله الاولى على 5.17 من
الاسواق لكن نصف هذه الاصوات جاءت من حزبي
النصر والعداله الذين فشلا في دخول
البرلمان بينما كانت بقيه الاصوات من
الكتله القوميه في تحالف الطاوله السداسيه
الرافضين لترشيحك الجدار اوغلو فقررت دعمه
بعد انسحاب محرم انجي الذي صوت شطر من
انصاره ايضا لاوغان لا شك ان اردوغان كسب
في اعلان اوغان دعمه له ورغم تفتت تحالف
الاجداد يحتاج اردوغان نسبه مئويه بسيطه
تضمن له الفوز بعكس منافسه كالجدار اوغلو
الذي يحتاج كامل الكتله التصويتيه التي
صوتت لاوغان في الجوله الاولى وبراي
كثيرين بات اردوغان اقرب لحسم المعركه
الانتخابيه في الرئاسه بعد البرلمان لكن
نسبه التصويت تبقى عاملا اساسيا في يوم
الحسم زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات